[Music]
we have to find the HCF and LCM of 18 20
and 30 how do we find the HCF and LCM of
three numbers together the best way to
do it is by reducing all numbers to its
prime factors and then write them in
exponential form let's reduce a teen to
its prime factors first it is divisible
by 2 2 times 9 is 18 and 3 times 3 is 9
so 18 can be written as a product of
these three numbers so 18 will equal 2
times 3 times 3 in exponential form it
can be written as 2 multiplied by 3
squared let's move on to the second
number which is 20 it is divisible by 2
and the potion is 10 which is also
divisible by 2 2 times 5 is 10 we stop
here as we got a prime number 20 can be
written as 2 times 2 times 5 and in
exponential terms can be written as 2
squared multiplied by 5 and the last
number is 30 it is divisible by 2 and 2
times 15 is 30 3 times 5 is 15 so we can
write 30 as 2 times 3 times 5 and in
exponential form as well it is written
in the same way now that we have written
all three numbers in exponential form we
can move on to find the HCF and LCM to
find the HCF we multiply the smallest
powers of shared factors so let's find
the HCF first shared factors are the
prime factors that are present in all
the numbers there are three factors that
we have to consider 2 3 and 5 and out of
these 2 is the only factor present in
all the numbers
now let's look at the powers of 2 we
have 2 raise to 1 2 raise to 2 and 2
raise to 1 again the smallest power is 2
raise to 1 so our HCF will be 2 how do
we find the LCM now to find the LCM we
multiply the highest powers of each
factor for the LCM the factors do not
have to be shared first let's look at 2
2 squared is the highest power amongst
these 3 so we write 2 squared first
among 3 and 3 squared 3 squared is
higher we multiply this with 3 squared
notice that 3 is not present in here it
doesn't matter for the LCM we consider
the highest power of each factor whether
it is shared or not and the last factor
is 5 we have 5 raised to 1 here as well
as here so we multiply this with 5 as
its highest power this is 4 multiplied
by 9 multiplied by 5 that equals 180 so
if you're asked to find the HCF as well
as the LCM of three numbers this is the
method you should follow
[Music]
you